in 1931 one of the nominees for Best
Actor never heard his name announced
because he was asleep in read wrestlers
lap only after it was all over to learn
he'd lost the Oscar to a slightly more
experienced actor lionel Barrymore to
present a special award for a lifetime
of work to pioneer movie maker Hal Roach
here is that sleeping Prince now a
distinguished actor producer and
director mr. Jackie Cooper
a lifetime of work there are about 92
years worth of things to say about Hal
Roach even the barest facts are
impressive he came here in 1912 two
years later he was a writer director in
1919 he began his own motion picture
studio and it thrived for 44 years Hal
Roach has produced just about every
conceivable kind of film dramas westerns
fantasies musicals swashbucklers but
because he was a man with a flair for
seeing the funny side of every human
situation he made a particular mark with
film comedy suffice it to point out that
Hal Roach was the man who discovered
Harold Lloyd and who brought Laurel and
Hardy together and produced most of
their best films other stars in his
stable included snub Pollard Charlie
chase Patsy Kelly Thelma Todd zasu Pitts
and a dashing young leading man named
Victor Mature
but his proudest achievement was the
creation of our gang the longest-running
and a lot of people think funniest
series of movies about children ever
devised you remember those little
rascals remember Darla buckwheat alfalfa
Spanky mcFarland
I do I was in quite a few of those
shorts but if I don't stop talking about
Hal Roach and show you some of his work
I think mr. Roach a man with a genius
for timing is likely to yell cut here
are some of the reasons why Hal Roach is
revered respected and remembered ladies
and gentlemen mr. Hal Roach
now
the presenter is usually the person who
hands representing the Oscar tonight
we've gone one better than that to
present this honorary award to you here
is George Spanky mcFarland
oh really this is the nicest thing that
has ever happened to me well the nicest
thing that I've ever happened to me mr.
Roche was when you hired me fifty-two
years ago but there was something I
never did ask you what was Hollywood
really like out here in 1912 Oh 1912
I the first day that I worked in motion
pictures
I received by $1 a day
car fare and lunch the car fare was two
tokens from in front of the post office
downtown to Hollywood wanted to take you
there and when to bring you back to Los
Angeles
the lunch was two savages and a banana
and the that is a little start of the 19
to 12 business but I understand the
thing has grown a little more expensive
today and people are trying a little
harder to save money in making pictures
and they're doing a lot of things to try
to curtail the expense and the only
thing I can add to that is my experience
in those days as far as making pictures
were concerned
I for example Mack Sennett when a
comedian for Mack Sennett did a Brody or
fell on his rear and the he fell out of
take a soap are papalo pile of oil or
something like that or something else
but anyway I got all screwed up to start
with I meant to say crap all to start
with
but anyway as I say meant but the hell
Road Studios did it a different way you
remember I said two sandwiches and a
banana well the property man after lunch
would pick up all the banana skins and
put him away for safekeeping then
anytime that a Hal Roach comedian did a
pratfall he slipped on the banana peel
and they slipped many times and every
time they did we use another thing but
the thing was great about it was the
fact that the bananas didn't cost me
anything in conclusion and that is this
that all these talented people that have
been trying to be winning Oscars here
tonight they all make their money in an
old-fashioned way they earn it